This is a paid for promotion by loot crate (japanese music playing in background)
(In Japanese Accent) 2000 year ago...
Hattori Hanzo
Placed his most valuable items
In a scared ancient box
and sent it...
to the future... (Time portal sound)
*box falls into felix from time portal*
It arrived! :D
How's it going, Bros
My name is PewwDiePie
Today,
(close up of Felix's sexy face)
I've waited 2000 years to make this episode
We're going to unbox
A box
from Japan.
(pewdie stare right into da Asian box)
we've got a lot of sexual stuff in here ( .)( .)
Close your door
put on headphones,
block your door?
*sexual_laugh.mp3*
Barricade your door.
b'cuz it's about to get sexual ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
This IIIIZ
"The Dream Of Men" -japan productions
*From behind camera* it looks even more like boobs now (. )(. )
This is how you get away with censorship on YouTube,bitch .
Alright, "The Dream Of Men"
*Felix trying to unbox the sexy treat*
Took me awhile to get this...
*Makes sure Marzia is not around*
A certain girlfriend
*you know what i mean*
Can't know about this item... ;)
oh my god are you guys ready to see the
drain moment eh
Oh my god. Are you guys ready to see ''the dream of men'' (Ooooh snap)
(I dont even wanna know...)
and we are
Oh wait...
*Pewds's drawing skillz*
*elevator music*
the song is "Local Forecast- Elevator" Kevin Macleod
just in case u actually want elevator music (don't)
yeah
three-man every guy's a while I Cyrus
(Art.)
''dream of men'', everyone
Hey look guys, it's Miley Cyrus (Furbulous, Pewds)
(Sub 2 Serpentgameplay)
all right ok it's a very classy way to a
percent some nuts to your guests
Alright... oh god
It's a very classic way to present some nuts to your guest
*fabulously eat a nut*
alright next time
alright
next item
oh sorry
oh hatori
*dafuq poods?*
that's hilarious
so now I'll be able to hear super well
let's try it at that
so now~~~
I'll be able to hear super well
Let's try it out
*enjoy the sound of seaside*
* Vid gets real quiet here turn up sound quick!*
.......
yeah
*did u turn the volume up like i told u? :)*
PEWDS.EXE (Not responding)
yeah
next time if you want to stick something
in your friends face
*imma slap this item*
next item:
If you wanna stick something in your friend's face
what would you stick?
what would you stay you don't have any
friends
*pewds thinking about willy*
you don't have any friends (i thought i have you T^T)
no surprises here but if you wanted to
stick something in writing people's
no surprise is here (senpai why TwT)
But if you want to stick something in random people's face (like sam pepper?)
faces
poop compare coming
POOP.
come here
come here x2
yeah you like that (senpai i dont want this)
yeah you like that put your face on the
screen
Put your face on the screen
*pewds sharing this precious moment with all his bros*
yeah like that smelly smelly
......with a poop on the stick
yeah~♂
yeah you like that?♀♂
smell it
SMELL IT!
edgert
hey edgar,
*no pewds I don't want your poop*
haha
ha ha ha
stupid stupid huh what's that cameraman
hahahahaha
stupid.....
stupid dog
what's that camera man? huh?!
huh you want to fuck you man fuck here
fucking dad you don't know
you want some?
f**k you man
f**k you
f**king dare you, you don't know me?
so this is nice one theme may the famous
power
so this is last months* theme, May
and the theme is power
I wonder if it will be as powerful as i
am and next one theme is dystopian comes
I wonder
if it will be as powerful as i am (not)
and next one theme, is Dystopia
comes out on the 19th
out of the 19
so make sure you order it by that make
sure you check out looking . com sighs .
so make sure you order it by then
make sure you check lootcrate.com/pewds
link in the description
it supports the show we can open it
together like a family
we can open it together, like a family
and if you use the code: pewds
and if you use the code cute you get ten
percent up which is a good offer
you get 10% off
which is a good offer
here we go I needed we see a cooking and
this is from simpsons that's the
here we go
I immediately see
a cooking...............hand
this is from...Simpsons (not)
*nope, that's the Infinity Gauntlet*
Infinity going there
this is being the clinic on land which
is also used in classic American TV show
*Camera guy thinking he's a farting buthole*
this is the infinite gauntlet
which is also used in
Classic American TV show The Simpsons
of the senses
that's pretty cool I need one of these
that's perfect
that's pretty cool
I needed one of these
so that's perfect
*kiss*
August is perfect right here this is a
dragon boll from
awww this is perfect for edgar
this is a...dragon ball
from uhh...
the famous anime took your cool I hey yo
you want this ball
from the famous anime Tokyo Ghoul
ummm....
hey edgar, you want this ball?
yeah that's right
yeah that's right he loves it
he loves it (sure)
we're going to share a walkout t-shirt
this is cool
we got a t-shirt
A Warcraft  t-shirt
this is cool~
how much you get feeling value finally
we have an action figure I believe this
see how much you get?
see how much value?
Finally, we have an action figure
I believe this is wonder woman
is Wonder Woman cute
it's cute (it's hulk)
I like it you know what I'm going to
keep this right here
I like it
you know what? I'm gonna keep this...
right here
who would win? batman vs hu.. the hulk whadda you think?
who would win back a mercy of the help
what do you think
we also get a pin
We also get a pin
yeah you you're bleeding and
uh...
you're..
you're bleeding
...oh
ye
check out woot.com sighs parents
check out lootcrate.com
/pewds
get excited for the next start you
guessed it back - here
CLAP x4 (SING ALONG)
♫ Get excited for the next item ♫
*SATAN HIJACKS VIDEO*
that's right, you guessed it
batman is here
can we get the helium can please
Can we get the Helium can please?
#PewdsblowsBatman
hey Batman and then at all right
hey~~~~
It's Batman~~~
alright~
why does it....feel like one of those f*ck dolls?
why does it feel like one of the fuck
dolls you know what I mean right fill up
you know what i mean?
do i fill up these? or..
these I want to know it's a distinct to
let with your big o his ass 30 pills up
I wonder how it's ass can fill up
*with yo dick*
*ma man*
oh, his ass literally fills up, nice
#PewdsBlowsBruceWayne'sAss
*MMMMMMMM ASS*
yeah but yeah
yeahheheheheh
ohhhhhh duck yeah
don't look at me like that you ducking bitch
look at me like that fucking bitch we
got to tell your parents
what you gonna do? tell your parents
oh yeah yeah pump that shit Batman look
like someone has been jerking off a bit
oh yeah♂
yeah pump that shit batman
looks like someone have been jerking off a bit too much
too much am i right Batman found it
AM I RIGHT batman?
pound it~
oh yeah any of a number for my saying
this league
hell yeah
*iPhone ringtone*
Uhhm
So I need a plumber
for my...sink
It's starting to leak when I...put water in it
when water in it so for the next item
So for the next item
we're going to bed back back
Ahh!!
BATMAN...BATMAN!
JESUS
*Poods tries to get him off*
BAT....
AH!
back back back
BATMAAN!
*Poods breathes*
BATMAAN! *Upset*
*THE SON OF A MONSTER WHO STARTED ALL OF THIS*
I wonder why I am getting kicked out, I don't understand
I wonder why we're getting kicked out I
don't know
Huhahahahah
oh yeah yeah but I bet man yeah fix that
Haloo
*Inaudible*
I give a farm batman*
Did ya ave' a sista
all right next I please man
ALRIGHT, next item please!
Eh..heh heh
*High pitched laugh*
Hey Batman?
*RIP*
o.o up
OHH!
OW!
*Poods laughs with no sympathy*
I final i am the moment we all been
waiting for
Alright...
Final item
The moment we've all been waiting for...
To watch pewdiepie get a butt massage
watch peopie get a butt massage is it
nice
Is it nice? Is it...discomforting?...
is it just comforting ok so this is how
it looks like it's very pretty
*FLOP*
Okeh. So this is how it looks like it's *Very pretty*
I would you put this on your butt we
have to put it on my client who wants to
Uhh..Would you put this on your butt??
We have to put it on my butt
Who wants to put it on my butt? *EW NO POODS!*
put it on my back
no my michaelina put it away
*NOPE*
Mi... MICHAEL DUNNT WANNT TA PUT IT ON MY BUTT?
*Michael snorts*
this is real sticky it's going to go on
my hands
this is real sticky
its gonna go on my ass
my concern is that if it's not
comforting
My concern is that.. if
it's not comforting, I literally can't get it off
I really can't get it off because it's
blew into my axe you know when i started
becus its glued to my ass
Ya know when I started PewDiePie *nostalgia*
. by five years ago I did not see myself
putting on
5 years ago
I did not see myself... putting on but massage
but massage for millions of people you
like the first time you guys in my hands
For millions of people
(Do you like this)
First time you guys see my ass :D
how you get like super micro help you
come on
How you guys like this??
Michael HELP ME!
(come on)
Okay this my ass #PewDiePieAssRevealed
ok this is my ass it's on Michael can
you help me
It's on
Michael can you help me?!!
*Michael splutters*
Michael adjust it right away doing
Michael!
Adjust it
Oewww...
AH! MICHAEL WHAT ARE YOU DOING!?... DAFUK MAN?!
buck some fun and you can we're down to
only my second touch my ass you know
*PEWDS FACE AFTER GETTING RAPED* (by a man)
Freakin' weirdo
Only Marzia can touch my ass... you know that!
that
thank you want to give it to be a little
bit
Thank you
Little bit more...Gi... Gimme some little bit more
ok
*anal button sounds*
Okaaayy!
who oh I like get everything in buttons
on it is it was up like that gets a
Ooh!
OOO!
I LIKE IT *THIS TIME HE GETS RAPED BY FEMALE*
if its like em.. butt massage
*realizing* IT A BUTT MASSAGE
ooh
ah
oh my I don't like that
Gets a little too intense  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
little too intense
the best thing about this is that i can
wear it
The best thing about this is that..I can wear it
whilst at work while I'm work ok give me
up the butt a little bit is that have
*sounding like an automated voice* Whilst at work
While at work
Okeh... Can we up the butt a lil' bit?
Cause I.. I want more  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) v2.0
more boom-boom up
*Poods shouting because he's butthurt*
I change the setting ah how do I take it
back
AH I CHANGED A SETTING!!!!!
AHHH!
It's.....
AHHHHH!
HOW DO I CHANGE IT BACK?!?!?!
oh it's like tiny hands are biting my
ass
*INHALE* ugh its like tiny ants are biting my ass
♫ Sad melody as pewds butt dies ♫
yeah
look at me
don't look at me!
yeah
OAWHHH!
oh no more
UOGGHHH... NO MORE!
BATMAN!
SAVE MEH!
God
GAWD DAMMIT SAVE MEH :'(
OOAWH!
yeah
GET IT OFF!
ya guys god dammit
GET IT OFF GUYS GOD DAMMIT
yeah
*poke*
AAH!
god damn it
COT DAMMIT!
AHHH ITS INSANITY
yep that's sexual harassment
OAHHHHHH!
*poke*
OAHHH!
*hut huf*
That's sexual harassment *to yourself pewds*
All you know... we got that on camera
how do you know we got that on camera .
- ah
*karma* OWH COT DAMMIT
*PEWDS SCREAMS*
♫♫♫ SAD ASS MUSIC ♫♫♫
I told you to lock the door all right
right now Richards together grand I calm
i told you to lock the door...alright?
ri ri ri... just chek out loo loo lootcr8.com/Pewds
/ boots and coat cute
enter the code: Pewds
They're our sponsor
they're our sponsor they're literally
the only one I really appreciate that
they are literally the only one *hysterical laugh*
i really appreciate that you guys checked out my channel to support the show. Thank you so much
you guys check them out to support the
show
thank you so much it helps to keep going
and we can keep finding which items and
it helps us to keep going and it helps us find items and which shit like that
shit like that
sure , spirits ten percent off purpose
10% Off!
*pewds kisses you*
*BROFIST*
oh it's soft
*Outro* Click for more videos!
yeah
hey want oh my god it smells like at my
friend's girl like you
Felix-Hey you want
Camera man-OMG IT PROBABLY SMELLS LIKE ASS
SMELLS LIKE ASS!!!
EUGHGUUGUHUH *laughter*